God bless Steven Spielberg he's a big
fan right dude the way I got that deal
was crazy
I uh we get a phone call she one of the
Jabberwockies
I take off the mask
even Steven used to open for me
yeah it was crazy it was ludicrous was
late
I got this now that he just floated out
and uh but no I uh I we get a phone call
right after coming in hot my second one
and uh and we go to amblyn I thought it
was a development meeting right where
you just talk you know what I mean and
or general I'm sorry a general meeting
and uh and just yeah I'll tell you about
me you told me about you and then we
leave and pretend that never happened
yeah yeah and that's what usually
happens in these meetings and then uh I
go there and the minute the the door
opens like every single person is like
Steven's such a huge fan man so happy to
meet you finally Stephen this Stephen
that oh my God Stephen can't stop
talking about you Stephen loves your
special and then I get to the meeting
and it's like jab and Holly the two
exacts and then right away they're like
Stephen can't stop talking about you and
I'm like hey look are you talking about
Steven from accounting
like literally yeah yeah because it's
like there's no [ __ ] way and I tell
this story all the time because
literally that's exactly how I felt
there's no way Mr Spielberg is a
phantomime there's no [ __ ] way yeah
and they're like no it's Spielberg wants
to make a movie with you do you have an
idea is there a movie idea you want to
pick and I pitched Easter Sunday and it
was that fast man they just said yes
great they said yes and then script yes
and then he was involved every step of
the way man from taking to the director
picking the cast everything wow it was
all him that's so cool and do you want
to keep acting oh I love it you like it
I really want to get behind that camera
man you interact huh I love it man I
love it there's something about it like
I like pulling I like pulling certain
things out of people like I enjoy it
like I can see it and I you know yeah
like I like like I'll watch things and
it's not like I'm watching it to enjoy
I'm watching it because I'm trying to
break it down I'm pretty sure you do the
same thing yeah you critique things
you're like you get frustrated when you
see it like I don't know how many times
I watch someone go [ __ ] why'd he do that
yeah you didn't have to do that or I'll
get mad at the camera Why didn't go wide
on that one yeah and they follow him
what happened to the [ __ ] back shot
like God damn now do you still have that
thing that wants because you got your
own movie now but do you still have a
thing that wants the industry acceptance
because 2015 you're making good money
but you're about to quit because you
can't sell a special I was eating dinner
with your managers and they were telling
me you were doing a sitcom and I was
like why it's so much work you're
probably making so much more money doing
the thing you truly love with no suits
telling you what notes are is it this
thing you see it's the thing of what I
said earlier it's like it's it's making
my mom proud
is she not already no it's like it's
like
no but it's just like he knows
no but what I'm trying to get at man is
like it's it's hard to explain to people
no it's not you know we all get it we
know that this is kind of a [ __ ] up
country that we live in and it's
starting to turn you know for the better
we got we got younger Minds now that are
thinking a little bit better you know
but they didn't see the hardship that my
mom went through right like you know I
tell this story all the time like when
when my mom and dad divorced and we just
wanted to color TV and we were at we're
at Sears filling out these raffle
tickets like I think she made me Robert
and Gemma we just adopted Gemma you know
she just came to this country and then
we're winning we're just filling out
these raffle tickets man we were going
at it for like three hours and I think
all these other families sawing us do it
but we just loaded up this [ __ ]
raffle drum and we had about a thousand
raffle tickets and we just wanted that
TV and we [ __ ] won it we won that TV
and we had to go up the stairs and
everyone was claiming the prizes to
going up the the escalator and and my
mom loves kids right this is like
1982-ish 83-ish and we're going up the
escalator and my mom loves little kids
and she saw this little white kid right
and she goes oh hi she loves it like oh
my God hi what's your name what's your
name and this [ __ ] kid turns around
and goes like this
and we all froze
like I I didn't even know what the [ __ ]
that was I was a military kid so that
type of racism we didn't really see
because we were all mixed you know I
mean like I've seen Tiger Woods before I
know what that is that's a black man
with a Asian woman or I know what I look
like I'm a white dad with an agent like
we we it was normal for you it's normal
yeah so now now that my mom and dad's
divorced and we're not on the base and
now we're at a mall in America we just
came from the Philippines
and this kid pulls his eyes back and
then my mom not reacting in any way
because back then if she does she's in
trouble oh wow what are you yelling at
that kid for oh he's joking around lady
you [ __ ] go back to your country oh
wow and that's the type of racism that
my mom has to deal with that's why
they're submissive how does she respond
even though my mom will [ __ ] up all of
you in this room yeah my mom's got a
mouth on her but imagine that
environment like I know my mom but she
froze and then we all froze and I was
just like yo and I remember I think I
was like 11 or whatever 12 and I was
just like the [ __ ] was that yeah and my
mom was like no no no don't worry he's
just being funny Joe said he's being
funny don't worry like that so when you
see that [ __ ] yeah that's why you do the
TV show ah
um you get an emotional yeah
because maybe that's your way of making
some change
and then somebody else's mom doesn't
have to go through that same thing there
you go so when they say
are you gonna do that accident again
[ __ ] I'm gonna do 53 years of
that accent you should so there wow we
got all emotional [ __ ] that's beautiful
man you know you know that's what that
is so when you hear [ __ ] like that you
just you're just like God damn like shut
the [ __ ] up well what what there's
people that that live in this country
that aren't heard yeah and it's
important
you know I want to see Hassan Minaj's
dad yeah
I love her song I Can't praise the guy
enough I love him but I also want to see
his dad's story yeah yeah and we need
that opportunity we need to hear that
accent I want to hear every [ __ ]
accent because there's every accent
lives here Akash Akasha said something
to me that I thought was great and he
was talking about a
when people make fun of like his mom's
accent or his dad's accent and uh you
said you could phrase it better but you
were like I love their accent I think
their accent's beautiful yeah like yeah
not insult to me like if yeah if you
asked me to do an accent for an audition
I'm not offended I'm only offended if
the joke is the accident that's exactly
if you're just a funny person that I
said in the movie yeah yeah the joke's
not an ax the joke's not the accent yeah
yeah the only time the joke is the
accent is when the person that's doing
the joke yeah isn't
and I'm just like the differences
between Asian people if you listen to
the joke I I break it down so good yeah
oh that's a great [ __ ] bit Yeah into
the [ __ ] bit that's why if you try
and see this cancel culture try and
cancel me yeah you'll see it look look
at the comments they got my back yeah
because I do it the right way only if
they have an accent yeah and I think
there's a little self-loathing in that
oh an accent is offensive I can't be
funny with an accent my uncle is the
funniest guy I know has a strong accent
yeah [ __ ] hysterical exactly so if
it's a funny guy with an accent that's
my uncle that's to your point that's
beautiful to see that on exactly but if
the jokes and what is it what is it
about
that that you don't want to hear because
now when you say that to me now I'm mad
at you because that sounds like
Prejudice who doesn't want to hear it
that's but that's what I don't
understand Andrew yeah like what is it
about that accent that you're not liking
because what you're saying to me is you
don't like hearing my mom's voice can I
tell you what it is it's the fact that
you're selling out a volcano because if
you were selling 10 tickets at the
Schaumburg improv nobody gives a [ __ ]
what you're saying about the accent and
I think when you get reach a certain
amount of success I think that humans
naturally we have this feeling and
that's where we have to tear down the
people that maybe we create or tear down
the successful ones because they make us
feel insecure and the only thing that
they can go to for you that they feel
because they can't say you're not
crushing right they can't say oh he's
not funny because they're talented 30
000 people there that are gonna that are
gonna say well actually yeah he was
crushing I came here every single time
he comes there's really nothing that
there can be critical about I'd say the
industry gave it to you they can't say
it didn't work yourself no right yeah
yourself right and you're up there and
you're crushing and you've probably been
in these like you've told us two or
three scenarios that were really tricky
ones so you ended up succeeding in like
on your way up you probably have maybe
200 300 more of ones just like that
shitty rooms that you entered then you
flipped because you're Talent so
there's really nothing that they can do
to take it away and what what breaks my
heart a little bit is it feels like
you're a bit insecure about it it's like
this is something that you're a lot this
your life is something that is hilarious
to you is something that you find funny
and these people also find funny and
love hearing like who gives a flying
[ __ ] what three people say when forty
thousand are coming out to the volcano
yeah like is it don't even don't even
put sorry in trouble like don't even put
that out there don't even give them any
credibility and maybe hurt more because
it is such a vulnerable thing like your
mom it seems like you look at her the
way I look at my mom which is the most
beautiful wonderful person and I feel
like I'm doing I'm paying homage almost
yeah and then when you're [ __ ] on
that it's like you're attacking this
character that is the actual person I
love more than anyone yeah and that's
exactly about that yeah
yeah that's exactly how I feel yeah yeah
I'm 100 and they don't understand that
you know it's like
I just don't get it but no Pat Marina
didn't have an accent
yeah I didn't yeah I did not know Marina
didn't have an accent I did not know
that but he's gonna go down in history
as
Mr Miyagi yeah and because that's the
Hollywood he lived in he's gonna go down
as aisle from happy days but no one's
going to talk about his legacy about
being a comedy Story comic and running
with Richard Pryor Williams we're only
going to remember him as wax on wack
soccer and that's the kind of racist
[ __ ] that we live in right so that's why
right that's why we gotta do [ __ ] like
this so so do you feel compelled as you
go to like this part of your career do
you feel compelled like
to leave a lot of people talk about
Legacy but it seems like your legacy is
a little bit more selfless meaning like
you kind of want to see change kind of
happening through your effect that's
exactly that's why my third special was
in the Philippines I just wanted
everyone to be Filipino I was just like
I knew how hard it was for me to get on
yeah and now that I have the door open
well then [ __ ] it I didn't make any
money on in his elements I sacrificed
all my money for that I thought I went
into production [ __ ] loved it I I was
supposed to shoot a third special in
Jacksonville I didn't tell anybody that
I went to the Philippines I got that
little girl that little girl lives in
the Philippines she's a rapper after my
show she got signed by Def Jam like
that's the kind of [ __ ] that's what I
want to do I want to I want to be able
to like Shine the Light
question Ronnie you know that that you
know I've known him since he was 17.
it's like so good the first thing I said
to myself is like we're going to the
Philippines bro I got a show he was the
first person I called when I left
Netflix we're going to the Philippines
all those b-boys live in the Philippines
they're all homeless kids we gave them a
shot
so that's what you want to do with your
success now
yeah I want to you get the door open you
keep it open I love that yeah it's Fire
Man